[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission nous
allons parler des des petites et des
moyennes entreprise de leur roule sur le
territoire et puis de la façon dont
elles vont se mobiliser pour les les
Jeux Olympiques que notamment qui vont
arriver sur ce territoire vous savez en
juillet en août prochain puisqu'il y
aura ici le le vélo le golf
l'équitation et donc les entreprises
peuvent participer à la réussite de ces
Jeux Olympiques elles nous diront
comment pour en parler Virginie fév
bonjour bonjour euh vous êtes la
fondatrice et présidente de StarTAC qui
est une qui est une entreprise de
formation au digital exactement on peut
dire ça et vous êtes aussi la depuis
quelques mois la nouvelle présidente de
la CGPME des ivelines confédération de
générale des petites et moyennes
entreprises donc quand je dis petites et
moyennes entreprises je ne me trompe pas
exactement c'est ça c'est de ça que n
avons parlé alors c'est vrai que on va
on va aborder tout ça mais dans le dans
la préparation notamment des Jeux
Olympiques c'est important pour pour les
entreprises hein il y a des enjeux
effectivement puisque il y a il y a
effectivement des des lieux très
stratégiques et notamment sur le 78 il y
a pas mal de lieux qui effectivement
vont avoir vont accueillir des
disciplines donc et c'est vrai que le
numérique sera sera important et et
qu'on peut s'y former il faut s'y former
mais il y a aussi d'autres d'autres
domaines Jean-Paul minier bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le le président de de
la société AX sol oui c'est une société
qui est à trrape et qui bah qui favorise
l'inclusion des personnes en situation
de handicap par des des matériels que
vous proposez c'est ça absolument c'est
une société que j'ai créé il y a 13 ans
maintenant euh et donc qui qui met à
disposition des des matériels de de
mobilité et d'accessibilité pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite que ce soit
dans le dans le domaine privé mais
également dans le domaine public en
entreprise administration et loisirs
voilà alors on va en parler parce que
évidemment bah vous participez justement
à la possibilité pour les personnes en
situation de handicap d'assister à des
spectacles d'assister peut-être au j
olympique et et vous avez une gamme de
de matériel assez assez bououflante tout
à fait on en parler dans quelques
instants Gal lebuf bonjour bonjour euh
vous êtes vous êtes un jeune retraité de
la polilce tout à fait vous avez fait
votre carrière dans la police et là vous
fondez
un une entreprise qui appppelle groupe
de sécurité et sonentre renforcé c'est
ça tout à fait qui va être une école de
formation un nouveau campus qui va être
basé à rambbouillet et où nous allons
former les agents de sécurité au
directeur de sécurité et c'est ça
évidemment et la sécurité va être un
problème important pour pour les Jeux
Olympiques c'est vrai qu'il a on va on
va en parler aussi avec notre invité qui
est avec nous en visio mais il y a
beaucoup de bénévoles qui vont
participer mais qui peuvent être formés
aussi hein tout à fait ainsi que des
étudiants avec des étudiants absolument
et alors en visio avec nous Dylan
Penanguer bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le chef de projet de
Coletti
forme c'est-à-dire de au fond
de de la formation d'éducateurs sportifs
c'est ça exactement alors collectif
forme dans un premier temps on favorise
le bien-être en entreprise pour les
collaborateurs et les managers ça c'est
notre c'est vraiment le fond de
collectif for et le volet social de
collectif form aujourd'hui permet de de
favoriser l'insertion des jeunes dans
les métiers de l'animation et
l'éducation sportive comme vous le disez
les Jeux olympiques de Paris arrivent à
grand pas on a besoin d'éducateurs
sportifs et d'animateurs sportifs en
France
donc voilà collectif form a vraiment
deux volets aujourd'hui al on va
peut-être commencer avec vous comme ça
après on vous
libérera Virgin F vous pouvez n nous
parler un peu de collectifform justement
et de et de et de du travail qu'il fait
et puis on va en parler avec lui
évidemment oui c'est un centre de
formation effectivement qui est sur le
département des
divines qui font enfin c'est vrai qu'on
manque on manque d'éducateurs sportifs
c'est ça alors complètement aujourd'hui
en France on a en moyenne he c'est c'est
des chiffres de 2018 euh 141000
éducateurs et animateurs sportifs euh à
date en 2023 on compte environ 150000
animateurs éducateurs sportifs euh pour
quel pour prendre un quelques chiffre
euh on a en France 360000 associations
sportives c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on
a même pas un animateur ou éducateur
sportifs pour deux associations c'est là
qu'on voit à travers ces chiffres euh un
manque cruel d'éducateurs sportifs
c'est quoi un éducateur sportif par
rapport à un prof de
gym alors un éducateur sportif peut être
prof de gym on a on a vraiment les
éducateurs sportifs qui animent des
sessions sportives dans les entreprises
dans les associations dans les
collectivités et à côté de ça on a les
profs d'éducation sportive donc les
profs de PS dans l'enseignement
éducatif donc c'est deux diplômes
différents les missions sont différentes
mais
à peu près le le le même travail sur le
terrain à qui comment on devient
éducateur
sportif alors aujourd'hui on devient
éducateur sportif soit par l'accès en
STAPS donc c'est l'université c'est 3 à
5 ans d'études ou alors par les filières
privées notamment le le bpgfs le brevet
d'éducateurs sportifs aujourd'hui euh
qui est une formation sur un an en
alternance mais qui est
payante donc voilà c'est les deux de
point d'entrée pour devenir éducateur
sportif aujourd'hui en 2023 et alors
quel est votre travail collectif for
alors collective form nous on favorise
le bien-être dans les entreprises et les
collectivités on aide du coup ces ces
collectivités ces entreprises dans leur
politique de qualité de vie au travail à
travers de la formation posture au
travail réveil musculaire gestion du
stress et du sommeil on les accompagne
aussi sur des événements sportifs
d'entreprise on crée des séances de
sport directement sur ces lieux et on a
notre volet du coup RSE notre volet
social euh qui euh avec en partenariat
avec les missions locales aujourd'hui
les écoles de la deuxième chance et Pôle
emploi on accompagne du coup les jeunes
qui sont en insertion professionnelle à
les inciter à intégrer euh des des
diplômes ou ou des filières des études
dans le sport dans l'animation sportive
euh on aide un petit peu la France voilà
enrichir notre panel et et le nombre
d'éducateurs et d'animateurs sportifs
aujourd'hui en France donc il il y a
deux volets si je comprends bien il y a
vos interventions en
entreprise c'est un premier volet et
puis un volet de
formation complètement voilà notre cœur
de métier aujourd'hui nous c'est c'est
c'est travailler dans les entreprises
donc on met à disposition des éducateurs
sportifs on met à disposition des
animateurs sportifs dans les entreprises
pour faire de la formation de
l'événementiel et de l'animation
sportive euh et on a vraiment pour
pouvoir recruter nos éducateurs et nos
animateurs sportifs chez collective form
euh puisqu'on manque cruellement
aujourd'hui de de ces acteursl euh on a
développé donc avec l'émission locale
notamment du du 78 euh ce petit atelier
qui dure 3h euh sur lequel ben des
personnes comme moi qui sont passées moi
je suis passé par l'émission locale par
exemple donc le le terrain je le connais
euh on on on on anime du coup ces ces
ces ateliers de 3h
pour aider pour sensibiliser les jeunes
à ces métiers qui recrutent parce qu'il
y a du travail aujourd'hui en France en
île-de-fance notamment avec l'arrivée
des Jeux Olympiques euh
voilà vous êtes situé où alors nous on
est situé sur poissie dans le 78 et donc
bon voilà on peut on peut s'adresser
alors c'est c'est donc une formation
assez enfin c'est une sensibilisation au
fond au au métier du de hein de
l'éducation sportive euh sachant que
comme vous le disiez il y a il y a il y
a d'énormes débouché et et vous on peut
penser aussi que l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques va favoriser le le le
peut-être le nombre de candidats à se à
s'intéresser à cette fonction et
peut-être favoriser justement le le fait
qu'il y ait plus d'éducateurs sportifs
qu'il y en a actuellement et alors qu'on
en manque
cruellement alors ça va favoriser je
dirais même dans les deux sens du terme
le premier c'est ben les jeunes qui qui
veulent s'insérer aujourd'hui dans les
métiers de l'animation et de l'éducation
sportive mais ça va également inciter
ben les Français à se mettre à
l'animation sportive on prend
aujourd'hui les chiffres de la
Commission européenne que 45 % des
Français ne pratiquent pas euh de
manière régulière une activité sportive
et que seulement 8 % des Français
pratiquent une activité sportive
quotidienne euh j'espère et on l'espère
tous hein les éducateurs sportifs euh
que avec ses Jeux olympiques de Paris
2024 on on va naître un petit peu voilà
il va naître en France vraiment euh une
une une politique qui va faire que les
gens vont se mettre au sport vont se
mettre à l'animation et enfin vont se
mettre sur sur sur sur le sport en
France
euh on prend l'exemple hein des de la
Coupe du monde de rugby qui vient qui
vient de s'achever en 2023 là euh 30 %
de plus d'adhérents sur les clubs de
rugby on espère que les JO 2024 feront
la même chose avec l'ensemble de nos
associations sportives c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas par rapport à des pays
anglo-saxons notamment on n'est pas un
pays très sportif en réalité
hein on on essaie de mettre en avant
aujourd'hui le sport et surtout les
bienfaits du sport sur la santé sur
l'aspect social parce que le sport
rapproche
euh l'état mène des campagnes de
sensibilisation autour de tout ça euh il
faut continuer euh c'est c'est un
travail de longue haleine on va y
arriver dans quelques années c'est vrai
que les les Anglo-Saxons les pays les
pays
Nordistes sont beaucoup plus sportifs en
tout cas le pourcentage de personnes par
rapport au nombre d'habitants est
beaucoup plus élevé que le nôtre
laissons le temps au temp c'est quelque
chose c'est c'est une petite une petite
citation que j'aime bien dire laissons
le temps au temps et dans quelques
années on espère les rattraper Virginie
vous vouez intervenir non j'allouais
dire que effectivement ils ont mais
j'allais dire qu'ils ont un panel de
formation qui est très intéressante pour
les ou et vamener SP en entreise c'est
plutôt intéressant ça cré du lien entre
les équipes ils ont des formations
nutrition des formations remises en
forme et cetera et c'est vrai que VO je
recommande aux entreprises du
départementader collec exactement pour
essayer au moins de de faire quelques
sessions pour leurs équipes je c'est pas
in V c'est oui avoir un corp sain dans
un esprit
sain c'est une chose c'est une chose
importante est-ce que dyan est-ce est-ce
qu' une forme tion spécifique pour je
sais pas des des bénévoles pour les JO
par
exemple alors on n pas aujourd'hui de de
formation spécifique à eux les bénévoles
sont sont formés directement par le
Comité olympique qui va qui va gérer les
Jeux Olympiques après on peut intervenir
nous sur par exemple le stress des
bénévoles le manque de sommeil donc les
formations qu'on a aujourd'hui autour du
sommeil puisqu'on sait que les bénévoles
vont quand même être mis à R l'épreuve
pendant ces quelques semaines donc on
peut complètement nous les accompagner
comme on accompagne aujourd'hui des
centaines de collaborateurs dans les
entreprises sur ces volets là
euh est-ce que c'est c'est vrai que
peut-être que vous vous avez dans
entreprise de sécurité je pense que vous
avez plutôt des intervenants qui sont
plutôt formés au au au sport non tout à
fait d'ailleurs dans nos formation pour
les futurs nous on est surtout
spécialisé dans les dans la formation
des agents armés ils ont ils ont une
épreve ils ont du sport bien sûr pour
les soumettre au stress déjà parce que
vous savez que depuis le 1er janvier
2018 les agents de sécurité privée
peuvent armé dans certaines conditions
sous tutelle bien sûr du préfet qui
donne son autorisation et pour certains
lieux sensiible donc oui on connaou donc
il vaut être il faut avoir une formation
et et physique et psychologique
d'ailleurs pour ça JEP Millard
évidemment vous vous êtes vous intéressé
à un public qui est en situation de
handicap mais oui l'accès au sport est
évidemment il y aura d'ailleurs les les
les J et puis les les G dis sport aussi
hein qui qui seront organisés donc c'est
vrai qu' on s'aperçoit de plus en plus
que le et heureusement que le sport des
handicapé le sport comme un autre avec
même parfois avec on a même plus parfois
d'admiration pour ces athlètes plus
d'admiration et plus de effectivement et
et et je dirais on se on se projette et
on va même au-delà du handicap pour pour
envoir des véritables sportifs en tant
que tel euh on le suit on l'accompagne à
la fois pour bah créer les conditions
euh pour la pratique loisir du du
handicap des personnes handicapées donc
sur le sur sur le sport en créant les
conditions pour accéder aux
installations sportives euh bon non
seulement pour l'accès sur les piscines
par exemple mais également tout lieu de
de sport et puis on accompagne également
des sportifs paralympiques également
notamment en canoé et donc des personnes
qui bah qui sont susceptibles de
d'emporter des médaill ider sur Paris
2024 euh voilà donc le sport est
effectivement une une composante
extrêmement importante et et
d'intégration et d'autant plus les
fédérations sportives que nous avons
l'occasion de de voir les sportifs
aujourd'hui paralympiques et et et et
sportifs olympiques s'entraînent
ensemble ou très souvent les uns à côté
des autres bénéficient des mêmes
entraîneurs maintenant de plus en plus
euh et avec une un respect et une j'is
un partage à la fois de de valeur et de
compéten entre entre les deux donc le
lien se crée là et comme il doit se
créer dans la société civile absolument
dyan panger justement vous vous vous
accompagnez aussi des personnes en
situation de handicap je je
pense alors bien sûr aujourd'hui
l'ensemble de nos formations puisqu'on
est un organisme de formation certificat
liopie nous oblige et et c'est c'est
très important pour nous aujourd'hui de
de favoriser et surtout d'accompagner
les personnes en situation de handicap
sur l'ensemble de nos formations euh
donc donc donc voilà toutes nos
formations tous
nos tous nos événements et toutes nos
animations sportives en l'entreprise
peuvent être faites à des personnes en
situation de handicap OK et ben écoutez
merci merci infiniment je vais vous
libérer comme ça parce que bon vous êtes
vous êtes vous êtes à poiss
là alors non là je je suis à quelques
quelques centaines kilomètres de poiss
pas avec
nous
vousz c'est pour ça que je suis en ben
vous viendrez vous viendrez une
prochaine fois avec plaisir parce que
c'est vrai c'est c'est une une activité
passionnante et puis c'est un besoin
vous l'avez dit pour l'ensemble de la
société quoi de d'avoir d'avoir plus de
contact avec le sport et c'est comme le
disait Virginie très important pour les
entreprises pour le bien-être des des
des salariés notamment d'avoir ces
activités qui en effet bah ça ça oui ça
ça rend plus en forme ça permet un
meilleur un meilleur sommeil une
meilleure récupération voilà une
meilleure présence au travail aussi
voilà donc c'est gagnant gagnant hein
c'est ça complètement complètement
aujourd'hui euh les dirigeants
d'entreprise qui mettent en place des
activités qu'on peut proposer et ben on
a une réduction de l'absentéisme euh les
liens sociaux les lien de cohésion entre
les équipes forcément sont mis en avant
la blessure au travail hein parce que
l'absentéisme est souvent dû à une
blessure en en service ou une blessure
un accident de travail les les TMS les
troubles musculosquelletiques euh donc
voilà ça coûte cher aux entreprises les
actions qu'on peut proposer non pas
forcément un coût
faramineux mais ça rapproche ça
rassemble et et ça augmente forcément
les lien de cohésion entre les
collaborateurs merci beaucoup et à très
bientô sur sur ce plateau on fera du
sport
ensemble merci beaucoup à très bientôt
alors on
va gel le buf à la
sécurité pour qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé à créer cette entreise qu'est-ce
qui m'a créé parce que après 30 années
passé dans ces forces intérieures je
vouis j'ai voulu faire autre chose VO
voir voir autre chose si quoi on peut on
peut raconter ce que vous non je non
voilà c'est voilà donc j'ai passé 30
années c'était une très très belle
institution voilà je suis parti pour des
raisons personnell et parce queis je
pouvais partir à la retraite voilà
pourquoi bah parce que déjà savis qu'il
y avait les Jeux Olympiques qui
arrivaient et aussi ce qui qui m'a fait
déclencher c'est depuis que la sécurité
privée peut être armée depuis le 1er
janvier donc
2018 voilà donc avec Monsieur Renault on
a décidé de créer ce cette os organis
mon associé assci euh SR production on a
décidé de créer cet organisme de
formation qui sera spécialisé donc dans
la formation de ces agents de sécurité
privé en passant aussi par les nouvelles
technologie comme le drone pour les
sécurité privée qui est qui est
aujourd'hui autorisé ah oui voilà donc
on sait que pour ces Jeux Olympiques
l'objectif est de recruter à peu près
15000 agents de sécurité et de les
former c'est un gros Allan ça déjà 15000
ouais ça n a commencé voilà il faut
savoir que pour ces Jeux Olympiques par
jour il faudra entre 17 17000 agents de
sécurité par jour jusqu'à des points de
22000 personnes àon de sécurité par jour
ouais c'est évident que c'est c'est l'
l'un des enjeux essentiel de CJ on l'a
vu la Coupe du monde de rugby par
exemple on parlait tout à l'heure ça
s'est très bien passé il y a eu aucun
aucun incident euh bon là c'est vrai que
le le monde entier va regarder la France
et il faut que ça se passe bien quoi
tout à fait puis il faut savoir que ce
métier la sécurité privée est un métier
un peu tendu que beaucoup de personnes
ne veulent pas y aller on sont ne
veulent pas aller dans la sécurité
privée par rapport pour par rapport je
veux dire aux salaires qui sont assez
bas ah oui pas trop d'intéressement à ce
métier c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui nous
centre de formation on va essayer de
comment dire de rétablir un peu ce lien
avec ces personnes qui ont quitté qui
ont quitté ce métier de la sécurité
privée qui qui c'est quoi le profil
idéal d'un
pas il y a pas vraiment de profil je
veux dire il y a pas vraiment de profil
il faut une personne qui est bien
équilibrée et qui oui ça non je veux
dire il faut être bien équilibré parce
que je suppose que dans les dans les
gens qui viennent vous voir il y a un
peu des bagarurs on pas on recherche on
n pas recherche pas de ce profil de
bagareur ou ce profil de de mercenaire
ou autrees qui viendrait de voilà c'est
pas du tout ça on je sais bien c'est
pour ça que c'est important de le dire
on a besoin de personnes qui sont bien
équilibrées qui seront au contact du
public pour les Jeux Olympiques qui
auront un rôle aussi d'AC
oui c'est ça c'est aussi de l'accueil
c'est voilà faut être aussi accueillant
qu'être qu'être sûr de soi et
pouvoir aider à la
sécurité alors là vous ouvrez en janvier
hein rouill
tout les jeux olympiques c'est juillet
c'est juillet c'est ça ça veut dire que
la formation c'est combien de temps
alors il y a des centres de formation
qui ont commencé hein voilàors donc
il alors chez nous ça sera 3 semaines
parce qu'en fait ils ont sorti une
nouvelle carte professionnelle
qui s'appelle le CCP pgse c'est une
formation on va dire qui a été un peu
réduite à 3 semaines pour former un peu
des comment dire des étudiants à part
avoir une carte professionnelle pour
pouvoir exercer ce métier de d'agent de
sécurité privée qui sera valable
jusqu'en 2025 voilà c'est une petite une
formation de 3
semaines le Pôle emploi il participe
pour pour les formations voilà oui quand
vous dites oui
15000 15000 qui V être recruté c'est
quand même énorme on sait à peu près
combien il en faut à Paris combienà dans
la France la sécurité privée c'est à peu
près 180000 agents de sécurité privée
sur toute la France savoir qu'il y a
un/ers sur l'île-de-fance 60000 ah oui
voilà il y a à peu près 60000 voilà et
alors ils sont enfin ils sont employés
par qui utilis par des gross par des
grosses sociétés des pees sociétés de
gardienage il y en a plein dans il a il
y en a une
trentaine sur sur les ivelines qui qui
utilisent ces agents de sécurité que
vous allez retrouver vous savez dans les
magasins ou pour garder certaines villas
voilà et les événements et les
événements voilà ouais là le ce sont ces
u olympiques oui bien sûr quand vous
dites parle de possibilité pour eux
d'être armé ça veut dire alors c'est
sous certaines conditions bien sûr alors
aujourd'hui la sécurité privée peut être
armée en catégorie B c'estàd avec des
armes de point ou catégorie D c'estàd
avec des matraques des bâons télcopiqu
alors on va dire un PIST un pistolet
genre Glock ou genre revolver en fait
mais ça c'est sous certaines conditions
et pour certaines missions pardon les
gens qui sont fermés 3 semaines ils ont
droit à ça non tout à fait non non ce
sont des agents de sécurité on va dire
normaux voilà qui sont qui ont eu la
formation formation qui sont pas du tout
formé à l'armement qui sont formé à
d'autres à d'autres modules absolument
et la formation normale comme vous dites
c'est combien de temps alors pour ce
nouveau CCP pgse donc pour
semes 105 105 he à peu près sinon un AG
privé qui va faire le module complet
c'est à peu près 5 semaines dans notre
centre et pour les agents armés ce sera
à peu près 8 semaines semaines oui c'est
çaationi voilà parceprès il faut
différencier catégorie B catégorie D ce
sont pas les mêmes et vous allez faire
les trois formations vous on va former
de la de sécurité oui jusqu'au directeur
de sécurité j bac+ 3 c'est quoi un
directeur de sécurité alors vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui pour gérer une entreprise
de sécurité privée il faut voir ce qu'on
appelle un titre de dirigant de sécurité
privée donc voilà c'est un titre qui est
inscrit au RNCP que que nous avons un
titre officiel voilà un titre officiel
voilà on est copie voilà donc et c'est
aussi pour vous savez tout ce qui est on
va dire service interne de sécurité dans
un hôpital dans une grosse société vous
savez aujourd'hui avec la nouvelle loi
ça sera obligatoire que ce directeur de
sécurité ait ce titre d'accord voilà al
parlez-nous un peu de de ce ce qui
comment ça va être un rambouiller ce ce
alors un rambouiller c'est un bâtim de
600 m² ah oui voilà que c'est dans reou
même c'est dans la zone des timoners
d'accord voilà donc c'est un bâtiment de
600 bâtiment de 600 m² sur plusieurs
niveaux où nous aurons des salles de
cours où nous aurons une salle qui sera
dédiée on va dire au tir virtuel avec un
logiciel de tir et ensuite nous avons un
plateau de sport des salles de sport et
nous allons utiliser le centre de tir de
rambouill d'accord et vous avez déjà des
des demand alors on a oui on a déjà des
demandes et comme on est un centre qui
va être donc agréé par le knaps et le
Knap c'est quoi pardon sous l'intérieur
c'est ceux qui régi les centres de
formation en fait d' d'accord voilà et
surtout de de la sécurité privée
d'accord et euh il y a il y a un coût
évidemment bien sûr qu'il y a un coût
pour il y a un coût pour les formations
bien sûr il y a des des formateurs qui
viennent qui viennent donner qui
viennent donner les cours qui viennent
donner les cours oui qu'il faut
rémunérer évidemment
non mais il y a il y a un coup pour les
alors vous dites pour l'emplo alors
c'est pris en oui avec donc l'arrivée
des Olympi c'est pris en charge
pratiquement à on dit maintenant ou
France emploi à partir du 1er janvier je
crois c'est pas enc ça vous ser donc à
100 ça sera pris en charge à 100 % ainsi
que leur frais d'hébergement et les
frais de repas voilà oui tout à fait et
donc et quels sont les les les vous
parlez
d'étudiants pensez plutôt des des gens
jeunes bah des jeunes qui ont qui ont
qui on qui ont plus de 18 ans bien sûr
qu'il faut
être au moins ans ne pas avoir un cas
judiciaire parce vous avez on est une
profession très réglementée ou et donc
qui est normal d'ailleurs oui tout à
fait donc et qui viennent faire leur
formation et bien sûr ils ont des
examens il faut qu' qu'ils a leurs
examens à la fin de ce parcours ouais
l'enjeu de la sécurité pour les Jos ça
va être évidemment énorme on disait un
mot tout à l'heure c'est vrai que voilà
PE vous pensez qu'il y a il y a des
risques aussi que
des on voit on voit aujourd'hui une
résurence parfois de d'actes terroristes
évidemment c'est une crainte que tout le
monde peut avoir euh c'est sûr c'est
pour ça que nous centre de formation on
est là aussi pour
professionnaliser ce métier et amener
des nouveaux des nouveaux enjeux des
nouvelles formations à ces agents de
sécurité à sécurité surtout avec des
menaces qu'on peut avoir d'attentat ou
autre et vous travaillez vous êtes vous
aussi un policier on l'a dit vous
travaillez main dans la main avec le
ministère de l'intérieur avec euh on va
essayer d'y travailler oui et puis avec
d'autres d'autres organismes il y a des
intervenants de la police nationale qui
vont venir dans notre centre de
formation ainsi que ainsi que des
gendarmes et de d'autres ministères pour
donner des cours oui d'accord Virginie
ou jepul voulait intervenir là-dessus
c'est non non mais je crois que c'est
extrêmement important
et pas pas seulement sur les sur sur les
Jeux Olympiques hein puisque avec avec
les enjeux que nous avons aujourd'hui
onué et surtout surtout que N DIRIS nos
forces de l'ordre sont extrêmement
sollicité aujourd'uii et de plus en plus
donc le fait d'avoir des relais moi ça
en tant que citoyen moi ça me paraît
absolument absolument essentiel et ce
que je souhaite B c'est qu'un maximum de
de personnes puissentincrire sur ces sur
ces formations et que et que l'aspect
financier ne soit pas un frein je crois
que c'est ce qui a été pris et compris
par le géris par le gouvernement de
façon à à pousser au maximum le dévelpp
de cette activité quoi vous disiez 15000
c'est un soit hein du du gouvernement et
de et des préfets de de recruter ces 15
15000 Laon et surtout de pouvoir les
garder et de les former parce qu'il faut
savoir quand même que la sécurité en
Provence la sécurité privée en France on
va dire c'est la troisème force
intérieure on va dire on va parler de la
première force intérieure j'ai quelques
chiffres hein à peu près entre policiers
nationaux gendarmes policiers municipal
on a à peu près ça fait 234000 personnes
à peu près ensuite on a nos militaires
205000 et la sécurité privée qui arrive
après avec 180000 180000 de sécurité oui
c'est pas loin oui oui vous avez raison
c'est trois forces presque TR forces
pres presque identique même si les les
missions sont pas sont past pas du tout
les mêmes missions mais aujourd'hui
voilà mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
doit compter et il faut surtout bien
former cette sécurité privée la
professionnaliser parce que on en a on
en a besoin elle était un peu mal vue je
pense au regard du public il y a
quelques années je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on est en train de la faire évoluer et
c'est donc un secteur porteur pour
l'emploi c'est un secteur qui est très
porteur pour l'emploi et surtout on est
comme on peut dire en manque de manœuvre
il nous faut euh c'est un métier qui
était un peu boudé h voilà il faut
redonner goût à des jeunes ou à des
moins jeunes de revenir vers ce métier
de la sécurité privée vous vous occupez
évidemment de ce qu'on appelle sécurité
physique si je peux dire la
cybersécurité par exemple c'est alors la
cybersécurité on va y ouvrir un on a un
département qui va qui va ouvrir on a
une personne qui est qui est en
formation d'ailleurs voilà ainsi que
pour les nouvelles technologies c'està
direire comme les drones en fait l'util
ah oui al l'utilisation des drones
i par un peu parce que ça c'est
important alors la sécurité privée
aujourd'hui avec le nouveau le nouveau
consensium de la sécurité on a le droit
d'utiliser des drones sur on va dire pas
sur des sur des parties privées on va
dire voilà pas sur la voie publique tout
ça vous savez il y a eu un problème
aussi avec la police vous savez
dernièrement sur les débats des drones
sur pour les manifestations donc le
drone oui aujourd'hui pour la sécurité
privée par exemple pour garder une on va
dire on va dire une usine par exemple
qui a beaucoup d'hectares une
cinquantaine d'hectares s hectares je
pense que le drone aujourd'hui est
capable d'ven pour assurer la sécurité
voilà ça peut remplacer certains
certains agents en fait d'accord voilà
et et
ça il faut évidemment former des
télépilotes des télépilotes de drone en
fait he voilà et donc ça ça vous le
faites ça nous allons le faire aussi à
rambouiller ouis il y a une question
qu'on enfin il y a Laurent voquier par
exemple qui qui est le président de la
Région ronalp euh est favorable au aux
technologies de reconnaissance faciale
notamment pour les pour les des
manifestation comme comme les Jeux
Olympiques euh c'est en effet quelque
chose qui pose problème parce que
jusqu'ici ça a plutôt été utilisé par
des état comme la Chine enfin qui sont
pas forc précisément des des démocraties
quoi euh vous avez vous avez une
position là-dessus non je non vous aurez
pas M prononcer voilà non c'est d'accord
non mais mais c'est c'est un outil ça
peut être un outil d'ailleurs ça peut
être un outil utile c'est c'est utilisé
on va dire dans certaines grosses
sociétés qui veulent par rapport S pour
faire comment pour faire exemple un
contrôle d'accès en fait oui oui pour ou
une porte
et nous on s'ent avec notre des secteurs
dis sensibles c'est utilisé ouais
maintenant sur la sur la voie publique
je pense qu'il y a un gros débat
absolument euh Virginie non parler un
peu de cybersécurité c'est vrai que là
aussi ça va être un enjeu essentiel pour
pour pour les j parce que il y a il y a
en effet ces risques de cyberattaqu
complètement qui peuvent tout
désorganiser enfin c'est c'est c'est un
risque énorme on est exposé forcément on
sait
aussi que ça va être de tout manière de
plus en plus on le sait de techniques
qui apparaissent il faut en permanence
rester informé il y a pas mal de
services maintenant qui permettent même
de former en interne les équipes
gratuitement par des services de l'État
donc de d'avoir des finalement des
formations de sensibilisation des
formation on en avait parlé d'ailleurs
ici même et puis il y a d'ailleurs sur
ce territoire et des écoles euh qui qui
forme qui forme très bien la
cybersécurité et et des entreprises hein
spécialisées qui qui qui se multiplient
et c'est c'est alors il y a des grosses
entreprises et puis il y a des il y a
des PME aussi hein làdessus vous en avez
je pense à la CG PME non ou oui il y en
a pas mal la cybersécurité évidemment il
y a une grosse demande et puis ça prend
différentes formes et puis ça évolue en
permanence euh bah c'est vrai que c'est
un vrai sujet et et parfois des rappels
de bonnes pratiqu en interne ça fait
jamais de mal effectivement pour pour
éviter absolumou des attaques oui oui
parce que parfois il y a des choses
simples euh à respecter enfin des règles
simples à respecter qui évitent en effet
des cyberattaques qui peuvent causer des
dégâts énormes exactement alors on va
reparler on va reparler tout à l'heure
bah justement de la formation au digital
avec vous mais je voudrais parler avec
Jean-Paul Mignard de de votre soci qui
était qui est à trappe donc à sol c'est
ça axol c'est accès solution
d'accessibilité solution d' ah oui c'est
c'est en verl en ver en anglais au
départ alors vous avez un parcours un
peu atypique vousz pas commencé dans
dans le dans dans les solutions appter
au personnes situation non pas dans le
médical ou dans le paramédical
absolument pas puisque j'ai un parcours
d'une vingtaine d'années dans le dans
des dans des multinationales agroaliment
en commercial et en marketing donc
effectivement pas du tout pas du tout
atypique mais avec la volonté une
quinzaine d'années de de me lancer sur
un projet de créer et qu'est-ce qui vous
a poussé à choisir ce secteur alors
l'envie de de j' dirais deer un projet
et puis surtout alors le hasard me l'a
fait découvrir mais d'un autre côté d'un
autre côté aussi l'envie de développer
une activité tout en étant j'iraai au
service des autres sur la deuxième
partie de ma vie professionnelle et
d'aider d'aider l'autre au sens large
voilà façon précise façon précise alors
vous êtes à la tête aujourd'hui d'une
entreprise qui a combien une vingtaine
de salariés on on est 17 salariés 17
personnes aujourd'hui absolument mais
avec un show d'action absolument
incroyable bah je dirais que notre notre
moteur est ce qui nous ce qui nous
motive notre notre fil rouge aujourd'hui
c'est c'est créer les conditions pour
que permettre aux personnes la mobilité
réduite de vivre comme comme une
personne valide et donc de créer créer
les conditions pour elle autour du
handicap moteur uniquement et comme
j'expliquais tout à l'heure c'est
d'intervenir à la fois à domicile mais
mais également dans leur quotidien et en
dehors du domicile c'est-à-dire de
pouvoir permettre d'accéder à une
entreprise pour pouvoir travailler de
d'accéder au loisirs d'accéder à une
administration et autres alors on est
plutôt je dirais sur une une niche de
marché puisque aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'accès sont réalisés au travers de avec
des professionnels de type ascenseur
ascenseuristes et autres mais il y a il
y a des cas dans lesquels euh il y a pas
d'ascenseur ces ascenseurs ne
fonctionnent pas toujours ne
fonctionnent pas toujours il y a des
maisons bien sûr vous avez des gens qui
habitent aujourd'hui en immeuble
aujourd'hui la réglementation un
immeuble de de trois étages même neuf de
deux trois étages aujourd'hui n'a pas
l'obligation d'avoir un ascenseur ah oui
euh voilà c'est c'est au-delà donc
euh tout va bien lorsquon hab tout va
bien lorsqu'on
habite voilà tout va bien mais au bout
10 au bout 10 ou 15 ans après un
accident de la vie en vivant dans son
logement un accident de la vie qui peut
être un accident de la route qui peut
être un AVC qui peut être et cetera les
personnes se retrouvent prisonniers de
leur logement 1er ou 2è étage et donc
vous avez vous avez des des matériels
alors on peut regarder sur le site de
votre entreprise je suppose mais vous
avez des matériels en effet qui
remplacent en qui peuvent se substituer
à défaut d'ascenseur donc ça peut être
par exemple des bah des simples rampes
d'accès he que que l'on fabrique qui
vont pouvoir être positionn le cas
typique c'est que nous connaissons tous
hein c'est c'est l'immeuble de plusieurs
étages qui est équipé d'un ascenseur
mais pour accéder au hall d'entrée il y
a de marches
oui et ça ce sont des cas donc voilà
donc on mettre ça mais on a également
pouvoir franchir des étages des
dispositifs monte escalier c'està que ce
sont des petites machines des diables
électriques sur lesquel on va pouvoir
fixer un fauteuil roulant une personne
va pouvoir s'asseoir et un aidant va lui
permettre de franchir de franchir les
marches et les les escaliers de monter
de 1 jusqu'à 15 étages s'il le faut dans
des des tours c'est un des gros euh
domaines d'activité le le déplacement
oui la mobilité la mobilité enfin ou
ouais la mobilité c'est un un des enjeux
des AG gens essentiels on l'a on
l'a ne pas avoir ce déplacement c'est se
retrouver finalement confiné et ça on
l'a tous connu il y a quelques années
avec avec le
covid et aujourd'hui on a des personnes
qui se retrouent non on a pas envie mais
aujourd'hui vous avez des personnes
effectivement qui sont enfermé chez
elles même avec un logement totalement
aménagé bien aménagé avec une salle de
bain adaptée avec une cuisine et cetera
et pour autant nous avons des cas don on
est intervenu sur auprès de famille ou
auprès d'association sur lesquell les
personnes étaient resté bloqué chez elle
depuis 2 ou 3 ans et ne pouvait sortir
queavec des pompiers ou des ambulanciers
là on leur permet de pouvoir sortir seul
ou avec un aidant familial et pouvoir
sortir de façon de façon relativement
économique donc ça donc la
mobilité en jeu très important et sur
lequel vous fournissez des
solutions il y a l'accessibilité aussi
bah spectacle des alors ça c'est un
autre volet que nous avonsou qui est
important pour nous qui est là en fait
on le crée soit en vente de matériel
mais une grosse activité en location de
matériel en location pour le tourisme la
location pour du des activité pour du
tourisme et pour l'événem cel alors le
tourisme ce sont ça va être l'ensemble
de nos de nos visiteurs en île- de-
France qui peuvent être des personnes
handicapées en situation handicap bien
sûr mais également des personnes âgés
des personnes obèses et autres prend des
des Américains par exemple ont du mal à
imaginer de faire plus plus de 500 m
dans Paris en marchant parce que chez
eux ils disposent d'un scooter à 4 €es
pour pouvoir aller au commerce du coin
et ça on peut le louer chez vous alors
on peut louer chez nous et en plus
on on équipe al on livre aux personnes
avant leur arrivée dans leur chambre à
l'hôtel ou dans leur chambre d'hôtel le
matériel pour le avant leur arrivée on
le reprend après leur départ que ce soit
dans Paris depuis des deux étoiles
jusqu'à des palaces mais également une
grosse activité également sur sur les
hôtels de Rod Disney puisque c'est une
une destination F Absolum donc a cette
partie là et puis ensuite nous avons la
partie
événementielle et là nous intervenons
pour créer également des conditions
toutes les conditions d'accès pour des
personnes qui
euh qui doivent accéder à un événement
donc ce sont les deux ou trois marches
pour
un pour une conférence par exemple qui a
lieu dans un dans un lieu emblématique
mais également permettre à des orateurs
qui sont ell en situation de handicap en
fauteuil roulant manuel ou électrique de
pouvoir accéder à une scène et pouvoir
ben finalement faire une conférence
comme je dirais comme n'importe quel
orateur valide si c'était pas le cas
c'est souvent on retrouve les personnes
au pied de la scène ou au fond de la
salle pour pouvoir faire leur conférence
donc on intervient régulièrement ce
genre de choses sur sur sur les grands
événements parisien et puis de des
grands événements comme le salon a du
Bourget comme comme bord de versaill
pour le salon de l'UTO salon noutique
Roland
Garros festival de CAN et autres Roland
Garros par exemple c'est c'est c'est
quoi c'est l'accessibilité là aussi hein
alors Roland Garos est accessible
puisquelle était transformé depuis une
dizaine d'années n on travaille depuis
10 an avec Roland Garos il y a encore
des zones sur lesquels nous intervenons
nous intervenons mais nous étions
présents par exemple pour la Coupe du
monde de rugby avec du du matériel en
salle de en salle de presse en salle de
conférence avec un élévateur une petite
plateforme élévatrice pour accéder
j'irais à la scène sur les avequel était
les orateurs puisqueen même temps que la
Coupe du monde de rugby il y avait aussi
la Coupe du monde de rugby fauteuil pour
les pour les personnes situation de
handicap et donc il y avait des sportifs
en fauteuil qui devaiit accéder à une
scène pour parler pour échanger avec
avec la presse internationale donc et
nous sommes à nouveau sollicités pour
pour les je olympique par Roland Garos
oui pour pour justement pour les pour
l'équipement des sales de presse et puis
sur
d'autres activitésou d'accord et on peut
dire quoi par exemple ou alors c'est en
construction parce que
les retard jeais nous intervenons un
petit peu en dernière dans le planning
un peu en dernière
DESS al on intervient depuis longtemps
pour j' dirais pour assister le comité
d'organisation déjà dans le comité de
candidature mais également pour le pour
pour les jeux euxmêmes ouis depuis
depuis les Jeux donc pour pour les
assister puisque y a nombre
d'intervenants de notamment du qui font
partie du conseil d'administration qui
son même en fauteuil Rand et qui ont
besoin de besoin de témoigner mais
audelà de ça euh donc le ce qui est
important c'est que le comité
d'organisation mais dans son dans son
process dès le départ a souhaité que les
entreprises de territoire soit intégré
au jeu alors évidemment on n'a pas pu
sur notre partie répondre à des appels
d'offre puisque l'appel d'offre est
effectivement global par contre nous
sommes soustraitant des répondants aux
appels d'offrees qui ont l'obligation de
de alors ça peut être des gens comme GL
event comme avas event et autres et
autres structures donc sont des gros
opérateurs internationaux et ils ont
obligation de solliciter des entreprises
locales pour pouvoir répondre au jeu
alors ça soit sur effectivement sur la
partie accessibilité mais également
traiteur sécurité et et autres voilà et
nous nous incrivons cette partie-là donc
aujourd'hui
euh alors on n' pas les réponses
définitives mais on est positionné sur
la cérémonie d'ouverture pour des accès
sur des trottoirs sur des marches par
exemple avec des petites res d'accès on
est on est positionné sur le sur la Fan
Zone équipe de France qui va être
également devant le l'Hôtel de Ville à
Paris sur le Club France qui va être la
grande alle de la vett et puis on est
sollicité en ce moment et on travaille
avec à la fois avec caratp mais
également avec différentes structures de
la région trans sur les transport et
l'accès l'accès au bus qui vont
transporter à la fois des sportifs mais
également voilà donc sur les jeux ce qui
est important de savoir c'est que les
structures elles-même sont accessibles
notamment pour toutes les constructions
neuves le vrai enjeu et c'est un gros
enjeu pour international c'est non pas
l'accessibilité de la manifestation
elle-même mais c'est tout ce qui va être
autour pour les les accompagnant
c'est-à-dire accéder à des hôtels
accéder à restaurants à des musées
évoluer dans les transports et le vrai
enjeu il est là plus que les jeux
eux-mêmes vous disiez ça fait combien de
temps 12 ans non j'ai créé oui à peu
près 13 ans oui et et quel est euh votre
regarde sur sur l'évolution justement du
du du rapport de la société aux
personnes en situation de handicap et de
de l'aide qui qui peut leur être proposé
il y a il y a d'une amélioration quand
mêmepression alors il y a une
amélioration qui est euh bah je dirais
vu du vu de la fenêtre des des
associations et des personnes concernées
qui est très lente puisque les premières
je dirais ça fait ça fait presqueement
une cinquantaine d'années que tous les
10 ans je dirais les gouvernements
successifs relanc et P ça c'est très
long à mettre en place bon c'est
d'organismes sont notamment des grosses
structures banques assurance et autres
sont complètement dans les dans les
clous la grande difficulté l'État est à
progrè prer et continuer à progresser là
où il y a beaucoup de retard aujourd'hui
dans l'équipement c'est c'est au sein
des je dirais des petits établissement
qui reçoivent du public des commerçants
association et autres sur lesquels ce
sont bah c'est long
c'est il y a un petit peu de conviction
à voir si la personne n'est pas
elle-même directement sensibilisée parce
que cas personnel jusqu'à une certaine
époque personne disait oui mais moi j'ai
pas besoin de m'équiper parce que de
toute façon j'ai pas de fauteuil rant
qui vient chez moi et le handicap ça
n'est pas que le fauteuil rant c'est
évidemment handicap cap visuel antiitif
et autres voilà donc c'est long le covid
a pas aidé les attentats n'ont pas aidé
puisque il y a eu des choix des
arbitrages qui ont été fait en terme
d'investissement
dessus on espère que les choses vont
bouger puisque il y a quelques il y a
quelques jours le gouvernement et Levia
Grégoire ont annoncé donc des
subventions qui a être misise en place
pour l'accessibilité des Grégo la
secrétaire d'État au handicap voilà non
c'est l'ancienne non non non non grégire
est au aux entreprises aux entreprises
et qui a annoncé effectivement la mise
en place d'une subvention pour les pour
les les les ERP de 5e catégorie donc les
plus petits les commerçants qui peut
aller jusqu'à sous conditions jusqu'à
pratiquement 20000 € pour les aider à
transformer le plus rapidement possible
et y y a il y a parfois il y a eu
longtemps peut-être un retard de prise
de conscience mais il y a parfois aussi
des difficultés pour des PES commerçants
voilà de s'équiper c'est
pas des Nores parfois complexes he il y
a desmes complexes mais il y a aussi des
aussi à monter des dérogations qui
peuvent être obtenues et pour faire les
choses de façon un pe peu différ c'est
ce que nous faisons nous sommes
fabricants nous-même hein de de de rampe
d'accès handicapé en fibre de verre donc
sur sur trappe et et je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui que sous condition on peut
tout à fait mettre en place une petite
rampe d'accès amovible sur lequel on va
aider la personne si si la pente est un
petit peu forte lui permettre de rentrer
c'est des investissements qui vêre dans
les 300 400 € ou 500 € donc c'est pas
nécess c'est pas non plus voilà donc il
faut ce qu'il faut c'est créer
effectivement ce
ce déclique cette volonté cette volonté
d'inclusion après des solutions on les
trouve et des subventions éventuellement
peuvent être effectivement mis en place
qu mais on est c'est un territoire qui
qui qui a une une grande force une
grande vigueur sur le la question des
personnes des personnes en situation de
handicap il y a la Fondation Anne de
gale qui vient d'ouvrir son centre à
Montini notamment c'est vrai que voilà
c'est je crois que c'est un des
départements les plus
inclusifs a des acteurs aujourd'hui il y
a des prises ce sont des professionnels
qui bouent association on a le salon au
Mureau la la semaine prochaine y
autonomie qui est effectivement
important voilà qui va qui va
effectivement qui pousse et fédère
l'ensemble des acteurs du du territoire
sur cette sur cette partie al je
rappelle axol est à trappe c'est ça nous
sommes à trappe est à trappe Virginie
alors on a deux sujets à aborder avec
vous on va peut-être commencer par votre
le sujet que que vous traitez avec
startck c'estàdire la formation h la
formation digit pour les entreprises
pour les les salariés des entreprises
pourquoi c'est pourquoi c'est nécessaire
de se former à au digital aujourd'hui
c'est plus une option c'est pres qu'un
nécessitétion si ce n'est que d'après
une étude 31 % enfin 31 % des
entreprises ne n'ont pas encore de
compétences numérique en interne c'est
dire qu'il y a encore pas mal de ça veut
dire quoi de compéten numérique ça veut
dire qu'ils n'ont pas de salariés qui
sont formés au
numérique exactement et donc c'est vrai
que l'EN si si je sais pas un artisan il
pas forcément besoin de se former au
numérique si bah en fait aujourd'hui le
numérique il est partout c'est qu'en
fait il est aussi bien VI c'est vrai que
ça peut servir aussi pour la gestion
pour la comptabilité pour votre
promotion locale en tant qu'artisan ou
en tant que commerçant d'avoir une
visibilité ne serait-ce que dans Google
quand on cherche à proximité un
cordonnier ou je n'en sais rien ou
photographe ou autre c'est important
ensuite important d'être répertorié
d'être c'est bien répertorié et tout
tout ça ça se travaille on sait
également que les avis sont très
importants donc si vous travaillez pas
votre iréputation un minimum au moins
répondre aux avis et alimenter cette
partie là ben ça peut être plus
compliqué il y a l'enjeu d'avoir une
vitrine et de de de dire ce que vous
faites et de vous faire connaître et
puis il y a d'autres enjeux derrière il
y a
aussi le numérique c'est des outils
c'est aussi je sais pas ça peut être
vous former à apprendre à à bien à faire
des belles créations publicitaires aussi
pour avoir des visuels propres efficace
pertinent donc c'est vrai que le
numérique c'est un peu partout et et
c'est aussi de l'organisation donc en
fonction des objectifs je crois qu'on
peut pas passer à côté aujourd'hui en
2023 c'est compliqué il y a justement
enfin une prise de conscience là aussi
de la nécessité de cette formation donc
il y a des aides aussi pour se former
pour se former oui alors nous on a un
organisme de formation continue donc on
forme effectivement les salariés euh on
forme également les dirigeants en
fonction du statut finalement il y a
différents dispositifs pour financer sa
formation euh que ce soit via un OPCO
mais également le FNE qui a été mis en
place Fond national de l'emploi euh qui
a été mis en place après le covid qui
permet aussi de créer des vrais parcours
de formation d'ailleurs il y a un
dispositif spécifique pour les Jeux
Olympiques et puis il y en a un
spécifique pour le numérique exactement
qui permet de financer des parcours sur
12 mois euh donc à cheval sur 2023 2024
et qui accompagne la transformation des
entreprise donc c'est très important
parce que du coup c'est pas des
formations ponctuelles ce sont des
parcours complets beaucoup plus plus sur
un plus long terme c'est ça hein
exactement qui permett d'atteindre des
objectifs concrets de transformation et
pour les j par exemple c'est c'est c'est
quoi comme formation en fait c'est il y
a aussi même d'ailleurs sur la partie
écologique he il y a trois sujets cette
année qui ont été validés donc donc en
fait c'est c'est très divers et ce sont
des parcours complets avec un objectif
donc parfois ça prend en compte
différentes variables euh sur les Jos
effectivement je pense qu'il y a des il
y a des notions d'accompagnement sur
tout ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui hein je
pense qu'ils sont éligibles à ce Tye de
finanement sécurité on a vu le handicap
on a vu le le besoin de d'éducateurs
sportifs ça tout ça est très important
c'est vrai que le numérique est
important le le le problème de la
formation pardon numérique c'est que on
a l'impression qu'on est dans un secteur
qui évolue constamment euh on parle
beaucoup par exemple d'intelligence
artificielle aujourd'hui on voit bah est
en train de d'évoluer à une vitesse qui
qui grandv qui nous dépasse presque et
donc il faut courir après les les
technologies comment on fait pour pour
former justement dans un secteur qui est
en totale évolution et en totale
innovation tout le temps déjà ça passe
par les formateurs oui bien sûr fa des B
formateur et encore une fois je va dire
un bon formateur c'est un formateur en
activité donc qui est qui qui pratique
c'est pour nous en tout cas le critère
vraiment décisif c'est la pratique qui a
des bonnes performances et qui continue
en tout cas parallèlement à former à
mettre en œuvre et donc ça Perm à se
former lui-même exactement mais parce
que ça évolue tellement vite que si en
fait on on s'occupe que de faire que de
la formation évidemment ça se fait
sentir après sur ce qu'on transmet donc
ça c'est un nos critères importants
ensuite effectivement comme vous le
dites chaque année les choses évoluent
on communique aujourd'hui sur Linkedin
d'e certaine manière demain ce sera
autrement et et chaque année il y a des
tendances et et c'est ce qui fait que
notre métier est
passionnant c'est vrai que ça agit dans
dans tous les secteurs la semaine
prochaine on fera une émission avec les
les les les spécialiste de euh
ressources humaines et et dans les
entreprises par exemple l'intelligence
artificielle intervient beaucoup
maintenant pour la pour le bah pour
former pour pour recruter donc il faut
il faut savoir maîtriser évidemment tous
ces outils il pas question que les
outils l'intelligence artificielle
remplace les les les DRH mais mais qu'
puissent l'utiliser c'est important donc
c'est vrai que ces formations sont
essentielles quoi aujourd'hui ben d'une
manière générale euh il y a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de formations qui sont
importantes ce qui est important quand
même encore une fois c'est de savoir où
on va parce que il y a tellement de
sujets vous l'avez dit lia lia c'est pas
un sujet à proprement parler on se forme
pas à lia on se forme à des outils on
forintelligence artifici voilà et on
définit au préalable et quel secteur sur
quel secteur on est-ce qu'on veut
réduire des coûts est-ce qu'on veut
innover est-ce qu'on veut améliorer un
parcours client en fait en fonction des
objectifs qu'on se détermine on n pas du
tout le même parcours les mêmes contenus
donc les compétences après qui sont
associé c'est vraiment déterm par
rapport à ce qu'on veut faire avec quoi
mais l'idée c'est justement que ces
technologie
aide soit pas une contrainte voilà mais
en revanche vous avez raison aussi
toutes les cibles sont concernés c'està
qu' a une époque on pouvait dire qu'il y
avait juste les responsables
communication mais aujourd'hui on forme
des RH qui viennent travailler leur
marque employeur on forme des DG qui
viennent travailler leur personnal
branding et et leur iréputation on va
former des commerciaux qui viennent
apprendre à prospecter comment on
utilise LinkedIn comment on utilise tous
les réseaux pour aller chercher des
prospects exactement donc tout toutes
les professions sont intéressé jusquà
ceux qui sont en mode veille comment on
fait une veille grâce aux outils
numériques et puis on en parlait aussi
pour les J il y a il y a il y a tout
aussi les les contraintes de la
cybersécurité là aussi et là aussi il y
a des formations alors il y a des
formations complexes mais il y a aussi
des conseils de base qu'on peut donner à
tous les tous les employés d'entreprise
les salariés tous les même ou les
dirigeants euh de des choses à ne pas
faire par exemple qui sont relativement
simples et qui mettent parfois à l'abri
euh attaque comme ça hein là aussi c'est
important et parfois ça passe par une
bonne organisation d'une communication
interne qui permet aussi de de voilà
d'éviter ce genre de chose parce que
c'est c'est aussi du à ça quels sont les
canaux qu'on utilise et et et quel est
le process effectivement en cas
d'attaque quoi alors vous êtes donc la
fondatrice de STAC cette cette
entreprise de formation mais vous êtes
aussi la la nouvelle présidente de la
CGPME des zivelines et on a vu avec avec
Gonal lebuf avec Mignard
l'importance genal j'ai pas demandé vous
aurez vous êtes deux associés vous avez
combien vous avez combien de salariés
alors pour l'instant nous nons pas de
salariés nous aurons que des
intervenants extérieurs parce que ce
sont des euh donc donc c'est vous êtes
une PME enfin voilà hein et jean-pa
miner aussi 18 17 18 salariier hein donc
c'est c'est on a l'impression que les
PME c'est le cœur au fond de de
l'activité industrielle en France enfin
de activité commercial et industrielle
en France on a pas l'impression la
plupart des entreprises en France sont
euh sont de exactement et donc
effectivement l'enjeu c'est c'est
comment comment on peut grossir comment
comment on accompagne cette croissance
sachant qu'un dirigeant de de PME
finalement il est il a une casquette qui
est tellement multiple euh que que les
enjeux sont importants donc
effectivement euh il faut accompagner
ces entreprises là et c'est la CPME
maintenant c'est pas c'est plus la CGPME
c'est la CPME CPM effectivement
aujourd'hui accompagne toutes entrepris
perdu le général
exactement et donc en France c'est quand
même 23000 entreprises hein la CPME donc
c'est le c'est la Confédération la plus
importante en nombre d'entreprises et
c'est vrai que notre rôle c'est
d'accompagner de défendre de représenter
à travers nos mandats également toutes
ces entreprises on est présent quand
même chez dans dans les conseils
d'administration à P emploi la CAF mais
également auprès des tribunaux tribunal
commerce tribunal prudom et cetera donc
VO est-ce que les les justement le le on
parler de ce rôle essentiel des PME
est-ce que vous trouvez qu'il est assez
reconnu en France qui a encore beaucoup
de encore beaucoup de bateau dans les
roues des des des entrepreneurs la
difficulté c'est que c cette j'allais
dire que on est moins informé on a il y
a beaucoup de réglementationou beaucoup
il y a quand même beaucoup de
réglementation hein de oui je crois que
je fais je lance pas un scoop en disant
ça France la réglementation est pas
évidente mais enfin en tout cas elle est
elle évolue en permanence et c'est vrai
que pour un entrepreneur faut être tout
le temps tout le temps en veille pour
savoir ce qui se passe et c'est pas
toujours évident d'être sur tous les
fronts surtout pour des petites
entreprises encore une fois parce que le
patron peut être le commercial en même
temps le RH et cetera et donc faut être
multic casquette et à la fois informé et
et donc voilà c'est bien de se regrouper
au sein de mouvement et de rejoindre
j'allais dire la CPME j'allais dire vous
êtes les bienvenus évidemment s G
et non c'est vrai que Ben le le le
président de la la Chambre de Commerce
et l'Industrie de de des Yvelines
Guillaume kerou
euh souhaite pendant son Montat doubler
le nombre des entreprises dans dans les
Yvelines évidemment c'est pas des c'est
pas des énormes entreprises qui vont se
créer c'est des justement des petites
entreprises des moyennes entreprises et
c'est ça qui est le cœur au fond de de
l'activité quoi
effectivement augmenter le nombre
d'entreprises c'est une chose après il y
a quand même des des destails critiques
une entreprise pour vivre elle doit
aussi grandir oui et donc et donc c'est
aussi l'intérêt des réseaux aussi de se
rapprocher c'est de pouvoir faciliter
les collaborations et et parfois ça
passe par différentes formes de
partenariat mais pouvoir grossir
ensemble c'est important parce que c'est
vrai que tout seul on on fait moins de
choses parfois et c'est bien de bien
s'entourer en tout cas on sait que
l'enjeu pour une entreprise pour qu'elle
pour qu'elle soit pérenne c'est c'est
d'être bien entouré aussi euh on a vu
bah grâce peut-être enfin avec la
politique gouvernementale mais les
entreprises ont plutôt bien passé la la
la séquence du covid hein il pas eu trop
de de casse ENF ça commence mais mais
voilà non non dir je pense que les ça
commence aujourd'hui parce que
effectivement on a eu ce que je vouis
dire c'est on est passé de là mais
maintenant ça a passé parce que il y a
eu effectivement euh je dirais les aides
et les PG qui ont été mis mis en place
par le gouvernement ont permis de passer
ça permis à certains qui étaient aussi
en fragile juste avant le début du covid
d'avoir un surcis voilà mais maintenant
on rentre dans le dans dans le cycle
depuis quelques quelques mois maintenant
de de commencer à rembourser ses prêts
et cetera et et et là on rencontre des
fragilités difficultés commen il y a
d'autres difficultés il a une
augmentation des desfillances très
importantes par rapport à l'année
dernière augmentation des des
défaillances d'entreprise et qui sont d
également à l'augmentation du coût de
l'énergie voilà il y a toutes ces
conséquences là qui sont qui sont très
difficiles passer pour les entreprises
il y a pas mal d'enjeux et qu'
effectivement qu'on fragilisit les
entreprises vous êtes optimiste quand
même ah ben on serait pas entreeneur sin
on était pas mais mais non vigilant et
attentif ça c'est clair ça c'est clair
et la difficulté que nous rencontrons
mais je crois que c'est du jamais vu
pour tout le monde mais je pour les
entreprises c'est d'enchaîner depuis
depuis 3 ans crise sur crise et
aujourdhui CR déstabilisation
internationale
internationalelationg et voilà et la
grande difficulté oui c'esttait on est
optimiste sans avoir véritablement de
visibilité ni les uns ni les autres ça
c'est le problème c'est la visibilité
voilà donc ce qu'on attend c'est le
soutien de nos partenaires financiers
qui eux continuent à croire dans les
entreprises et par chance pour vous en
tout cas vous êtes dans des dans des
secteurs porteurs euh que ce soit le
handicap que ce soit la sécurité que ce
soit le numérique merci merci tous les
TR remercie
aussi comment il s'appelle
Dylan ah oui non il est en photo là
laiss tranquille merci merci en tout cas
c'était c'était passionnant de voir
comment voilàah des des des des gens qui
viennent d'ailleurs comme comme vous
enfin qui dans dans l'entreprise vous
qui étiz dans la police se mobilise et
puis crée des des entreprises des
emplois des formations bravo merci à
tous les
tris
[Musique]